thank you
[Music]
this article is dedicated to Nick Don
let's hear it
none
all right Nick did you hear the latest
news it's gonna be underwhelming
um no what's the latest news California
has officially legalized
or decriminalized I should say
jaywalking if this doesn't
does that mean that like uh I get that
off my record no no it isn't no it's a
moving forward thing forward thing so
what does this even mean you still can't
fly
here's what it means if the street was
safe to cross and there really was no
traffic that could have hit you you
won't get a ticket for jaywalking you
can cross where there's no crosswalk as
long as it was safe to do it why was
this such a big deal before I'm okay
with that I didn't know that's what the
actual stipulation was I'm a big fan of
that because I think you should be able
to so so clarifying one more time for
the idiot in the room uh literally as
long as I deem it safe I just run across
the street as long as it's reasonably
safe for a reasonable person to have
thought oh it nobody was coming it was
fine Define reasonable person in America
does that also mean no matter what
though like what happens what happens
runs out and then like I I bump him with
my car
and it's not enough that's on them yeah
so you could still you could still get
in trouble for jaywalking like let's say
well if you hit them that's a total
different situation but let's say that
you were just crossing and you made
everybody have to stop and yeah you
should get arrested you will get a
jaywalking ticket you will still get a
jaywalk but in a way they just legalized
murder
that's true because if if I get to hit
you that means you [ __ ] up but I get
to hit you but they have to be fast
enough to not get hit exactly so then
it's all good because if you are
jaywalking and you stop oncoming traffic
in any way you should be hit by car
that's that's like New York rules yeah
like in New York yeah if [ __ ]
are in the crosswalk already and it's
not it's not time for them to go like
cab drivers will bump you yeah like hey
get back on the [ __ ] curve yeah I
like that because when I was in El
Salvador one of the main things I loved
about El Salvador was how yeah exactly
and all the pedestrians their heads on a
[ __ ] swivel they know exactly where
every car is that they're paying
attention they're you know crossing the
street because there's no like not that
many crosswalks at least in the area
that I was in yeah but they're all
paying attention they're all aware all
the drivers are paying attention all the
pedestrians too so it's all good so
that's what we what about that person
who's like slightly anxious right who's
at the crosswalk already yeah next
listen to me buddy you got a ticket okay
you're the only guy
he's the only jaywalker like seven in
the morning you need these examples you
need to run through everything
technically what I did was legal you
know what I mean because I didn't stop
traffic recap what you even did I
crossed the street at like seven in the
morning okay there's nobody nothing
right he walked on the crosswalk lines
actually and there was no cars I didn't
stop any traffic and I got a ticket
while I was ordering coffee like a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] little [ __ ] boy went into
the coffee dude I was so confident that
it had nothing to do with my jaywalking
he tapped on my shoulder while I was
like oh should I get the Americano
should I get a latte right that's what
I'm thinking in my [ __ ] head he tasks
me in the shoulder he goes can I see you
outside and I was like oh for sure
officer what's the deal like I thought
it was they gonna help him catch a crook
yeah I was like yeah like you know I was
like yeah I'm a blue belt Jiu Jitsu what
can I help you with
and he goes I'm gonna give you a [ __ ]
ticket for jaywalking and I got did you
really say [ __ ] no yeah
man that's [ __ ] but sorry what was
your scenario again
it's not important anymore it should be
you said he was Chinese he was some
Chinese dude wow I think the bigger the
car they should have the right-of-way
the bigger the car so a semi truck yeah
stay the [ __ ] away true because that guy
can't even see he can't even see your
ass if he smashes into you it's your
fault get the [ __ ] away right you're
like how can you not see it yeah
pedestrians get ran over us the
pedestrians you're using a semi truck as
an example but he's pleading a case for
his car because he's still in the top 95
semi semi trucks away from a [ __ ]
semi dude I might get a semi truck
here's the interesting uh a very
interesting motivation as to why they
did this
um they're saying that uh jaywalking
tickets are disproportionately given out
to low-income uh citizens or minorities
who can't really afford to pay these
tickets dude at the time that [ __ ]
400 ticket was [ __ ]
low-income minority in Pasadena one of
them
sir thank you bro for Hondo it was like
yeah it was like four hundo and it was
[ __ ] it was total [ __ ] because I
think I've [ __ ] driven like 150 and
it's not even before dude I gotta take
it the other day and it's not even
[ __ ] I was driving and I crossed the
double lines it's not even close to 400
wait 400 yeah
you're talking about foreign
I'm gonna get that [ __ ] dude
that's what he said maybe he's seen you
do it every morning bro but that's a
thing was that morning that was like the
day I decided okay I'm gonna be a little
wild you know why because it was the day
after my birthday so I was a little
confident I was like it's a good day
post birthday conference yeah post
birthday confidence thank you it sucks
that you must have been so pissed the
rest of the day now I don't even jaywalk
anymore well now you can it's job now I
can now I feel like I'm gonna [ __ ]
jaywalk because I got the eyes for it
but this this doesn't apply to Pasadena
though
you feel like you should do it more to
get your 400 worth yeah I'm gonna get my
money's back okay that's fine that's
good we take luck every day
I still feel nervous in the middle of
the street yeah we are jaywalking all
over the goddamn place oh I feel like we
obey the laws we also horizontally
jaywalk for some reason like so all you
have to you know you're supposed to go
you're supposed to go across the street
we like walk with the street but we're
in the street so it's like wow oh yeah
sometimes we walk like [ __ ]
sometimes yeah most of the time are we
jaywalking or are we marching and
protesting see I think that's the line
though yeah because what happens to the
people that are on the [ __ ] highways
that are stopping on the street dude
yeah like people that go on the 110
Highway and they start no that's fine
protesting the road no ice they don't
get they don't get tickets bro they just
keep putting the paper up over and over
Dude they should get something so so
back to an actual scenario though
the crosswalks you know when the
crosswalks got a red hand yeah but it's
safe for you to go yeah it's very
confusing for something because that's
your situation technically that's
considered jaywalking if you don't
follow the hand now you can go if it's
safe but now you can go now you can go
even if it's there's a red like there's
something that says stop absolutely
there's even a car when there's a red
light has to stop even if there's not
nobody there well it's the same as if
you were crossing where there wasn't a
lot at all okay I just want to be clear
because it's gonna happen just [ __ ]
run just just run it's good exercise
dude just don't stop traffic DJ run it
also looks like you're a little Mischief
but then if you walk and you just do a
little little small little shimmy looks
like you're running do you think do you
think that this change is going to
result in just a shitload of people in
your way when you're like driving down
Hollywood or something in Hollywood
probably yeah because people are gonna
take advantage out there I think you
could parallel park now
[ __ ] Jack your seat back
and then you wait for someone to be
doing this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I'm telling you and you just made it
legal that's the [ __ ] that's the [ __ ]
Purge dude that's the purge in our
street so you think it's bad for I think
that some psychopath people are going to
be doing all kinds of [ __ ] maybe God
dresses himself up like a [ __ ] car
seat so he looks like the seat
looks like this seat these guys just
upholster his [ __ ] self opens his
eyes
the whites of his eyes yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah well that was a chair and he's like
and then he hits you boom you just
[ __ ] go up the windshield and then
anyone wants you to be like we can't get
them it's completely legal nobody was
driving
can't get him no one's driving you guy
attitude you guys it was an automated
car
do you sue Elon Nick do you think you're
in that category because the senior
staff attorney says that for too long
jaywalking laws were used as a pretext
to stop and harass people Loki if
Colleen thinks I got harassed yeah I got
arrested
if she gives me the pass too oh saying
like if she was kind of everyone else in
this room except for Colleen was like
well you're a [ __ ] idiot Nick Colleen
was actually like empathetic and saying
like hey I think this is a problem I
think you got targeted so I appreciate
you yeah yeah rest you guys don't have
my [ __ ] back I'd love her back
but like at elac East Salt Lake
Community College they targeted students
so there's a specific crosswalk that
would be really slow you know what I'm
talking about no I'm just saying I do
have your back but at least
I'm like baby baby just shouldn't be
jaywalking and there was like there's a
bike cop was this guy a bike
damn it it was a bike cop and you would
hide so it's one of those where like
here's the uh the the like [ __ ]
thrifties or Rite Aid or whatever and
then where the loading docks it kind of
goes down like this okay and then so the
bike cop he can go down here I know that
bike cop it is eye level is the ground
so no one's a gopher yeah so no one's
looking at him and then as soon as
people like kids are just like oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna be late for class because kids
are always late for class they'd run
across the street
what a [ __ ] always wow on students
at a community college yeah
jeez that's [ __ ] man it's worse right
there [ __ ] dude do you feel like
these tickets were disproportionately
given out to low-income people do you
think like if you went to a high income
neighborhood and someone was like
tickets are always disproportionately
given out like look at the [ __ ]
street sweeping [ __ ] you think rich
people have to give a [ __ ] about that no
they're all parking in their garage dude
it's all it's a Target [ __ ] poor
people well that's disproportionate in
both directions the really rich people
don't have to worry about it and so do
the homeless [ __ ] trailers that have
been there for eight months that's true
yeah that's very true but really rich
people don't have to sweat it you know
what we should do everyone in the middle
next time we get more rich people like
Bobby hundreds that sits here we need to
ask them these questions hey you ever
got a jaywalking ticket before we need
to add that to the gym he's like yeah
dude hundreds of times it's like man and
then you ask him how much was it he's
like I don't know like 20 bucks
wait wait what the [ __ ] hey whoa ride
the guy
I I think I'm too I'm too like uh I'd
rather just be like I [ __ ] complain
about it later I should try though I
should try to like haggle with these
[ __ ] I don't know if I would
recommend that I think it's a try bro
I'm gonna try try bribing them yeah
walking ticket just escalated further
he's just like can I buy you a coffee
officer hey can I buy you an Americano
thank you for your service my friend
yeah I'm gonna find these [ __ ] cops
dude so new JK question is have you
dealt with Jay Watkins have you ever got
a jaywalker and then sweeping street
sweeping who doesn't get a street
sweeping ticket in La once every [ __ ]
dude I didn't even know you could get
double did you know that
like you [ __ ] I didn't know that I was
like sometimes I'm like oh [ __ ] I got
one already well I'm just gonna leave my
car here and then there's another one on
top of it the next week yeah and the
next week
no I used it because I was like I'm like
okay I have it on my car already right
and then so I'm like give this to me so
I'm [ __ ] driving around the whole
week and I'm like oh I can't find a
parking space I know I'll use the ticket
from last week so I'll park dude I used
to do that and then and then they'll
[ __ ] slap another one on I'm like I
got one last week you son of a [ __ ]
they might be checking that [ __ ] they'd
be like looking at the date yeah they'll
just look at this look at the street
address it's not the same [ __ ] street
that is so [ __ ] nosy for yeah or it's
like that one person who like knows
that's that's the portion that they are
in control over so they're like I need
to do this you're on his Beats yeah yeah
I like I'm the God of this block dude
[Music]